BRET BRET FINALLY TONIGHT,
THIS WEEK'S NOTABLE
QUOTABLES.
>> TO WHAT DO YOU OWE THIS
RECENT OPENNESS TO TALK?
>> ME.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MEET KIM
JONG UN.
>> STEEL IS STEEL.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE STEEL, YOU
DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> YOUR TARIFFS AGAINST
ALLIES ONE WONDERS WHO THE
ENEMIES ARE.
>> I LIKE CONFLICT.
I LIKE SEEING IT.
>> LET'S NOT BE DELICATE.
DID SHE HAVE A SEXUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> YES.
>> COMING OFF AS ANGRY
13-YEAR-OLD KID WHO HATES
DADDY TRUMP AND DOESN'T WANT
TO RESPECT MUELLER.
>> HE MAY BE A GLOBALIST I
STILL LIKE HIM.
>> THERE IS NOBODY LEFT THAT
CAN TAME TRUMP'S WHACKO
IMPULSES.
>> LET'S ARM WRESTLE.
>> CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
>> POLITICAL STUNT.
>> YOU HAVE THE MONEY CAN
YOU HAVE THE SANCTUARY
CITIES.
>> THE NRA AS IT EXISTS
TODAY HAVE IN ESSENCE BECOME
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
>> ONGOING EFFORT OF THE
RUSSIANS.
>> ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE A
PAPERBACKUP SYSTEM.
>> SERIOUS INVESTIGATIONS
DON'T LEAK.
>> GO GET DACA.
>> DON'T PUSH THOSE
DEMOCRATS.
>> IT SEEMS NO ONE IS HOME
IN THE WHITE HOUSE RIGHT
NOW.
>> BELIEVE ME, EVERYONE
WANTS TO WORK IN THE WHITE
HOUSE BECAUSE WE HAVE ENERGY
LIKE RARELY BEFORE.
>> THIS IS MARCH MADNESS.